but they're going to have their hands
full fellas because max fried has been
one of the game's best pitchers in 2020.
fly ball hit toward left nick marcakis
broke back now comes charging in and
nick handles the
first chance he has in left field
tonight
base is empty for martay and a bunt try
fried sniffs it out bare hand try fast
throw and got him by a step
good athletic play by max free to take
care of martay who's out number two
now jesus aguilar to the plate four for
eight in the series with an rbi
and aguilar with a drive out to left
field that is long gone oh
boy for jesus aguilar the solo home run
is his seventh and it's one nothing
marlins it's the first home run max
freight has given up this year
and you know anderson sends one deep to
center field back-to-back home runs for
the marlins in the first back-to-back
jacks aguilar in anderson and
both home runs no doubters
cooper getting a big lead at second
ozzie tries to keep him close
and a little chopper hit left side icha
ferry has got it throws off stride and
gets his man on the mound for the
marlins now with the two nothing lead is
sixto sanchez this is his seventh major
league start cunha coax is a lead off
walk so here is uh the red hot freddy
freeman
freddy first pitch swing hammers it into
the right field corner here comes ronald
flying around second he's on his way to
third he's got the green light he's
coming home there'll be no relay freddie
jumps on the first pitch tommy he
doubles homer cunha and the braves are
on the board it's two to one runner at
second one down for ozzy albies manning
clean up tonight
line drive left field at base hit here
comes freddie around to score brazer
jumping all over sanchez throw to the
plate won't be cut off hits off the side
of the mound and ozzie dives back to
first with a game-tying single
two young pitchers have gone off to
rough starts in tonight's third game of
the series
brian snitker's been pacing up and down
the dugout an awful lot yeah i don't i
don't like the the fact that he's
talking to max and now shaking his head
yeah that's not a happy look no it's not
something it kind of looks like max is
trying to talk to stay in the game right
well with all the injuries the braves
have had and rotate they can't risk
losing him and i'm betting right there
freddie freeman's telling max free
there's a bigger game at play than this
one
max free tweaked his ankle on that bunt
play and as a precaution with the
playoffs coming up they decided to not
risk any
further issues first and third and two
down for edge maria
lined into center field one in it bad
braves lead dansby on his way to third
base
adeni echeverria's first hit of the
series puts atlanta in front it's a 3-2
score
for daniel echeverria who's playing time
has been
very limited
little bloop into shallow right center
field martay coming on brinson coming on
can't get it ozuna streaks around he is
going to score throw gets away at third
and uh chavarria will move up another 90
feet
that one is smoked into center field to
base hit
rounding third brian anderson here's the
throw it's cut off an rbi single for
louis brinson and it's 4-3 now that's
what we're talking about there you go
great swing
chop to third echeveria with the play
over to first that will tie the game
runners on the corners
for aubie's who's one for two
corked into left center field what a
piece of hitting by ozzy he goes
opposite field again he brings home a
cuny and the braves are back in front
line drive shallow center coming on does
martay that's gonna drop in front of him
atlanta adds on it's six to four and
they are beating the marlins with a
death by thousand cuts type offense
tonight six for atlanta dansby the
hitter
driven towards center marte on his horse
back to the infield look at that ball
carry out toward the braves bullpen that
ball is gone
dansby swanson with a homer to right
center and the braves have exploded
again a five run fourth felt like 30
seconds brave scored five
and that's where we've been another
multi-hit game for garrett cooper
that's a good way to start the ninth
inning
and there's a good comeback for green he
got brinson to swing and miss
one on one out in the miami knife
a little ground ball hit towards short
dansby takes the bag off balance throw
what a double play
that's how you finish off miami more
great middle infield defense for the
braves
[Music]